so the idea that they put a rainbow flag
on the menu or they do well on the
website wherever it was and it's making
you mad people are like Cracker Barrel
was a family establishment how about
eating home aren't you if you're a
family shouldn't you be eating up my
grandparents never went to Cracker back
this is the problem with this fat
decrepit country just cause they say oh
come on down to Country Kitchen with
bonba no my grandparents straight
Catholics who did not support the gay
lifestyle ate at home my nanny cooked
they didn't get in the station wagon and
go down to Cracker Barrel and fill
themselves with biscuits they ate at
home it's an old family experience here
at Cracker Barrel come on down to
Cracker Barrel by the parkway there's
about 200 other people there and go
shopping in our gift shop no stay the
home